Student,
a former student of mine emailed me last night from a Lake Tahoe,
Eh,
where they had received six feet of snow in the past four days.
Can you imagine that compared to a,
what seems like a,
a,
uh,
interesting day outside here.
The,
uh,
the,
the western storms are really quite terrific this year.
Uh,
if any of you are outdoor enthusiasts,
uh,
so mammoth mountain in southern California received eight feet of snow last
week,
squab six,
uh,
Jackson hole between a six and seven.
It's really quite remarkable.
One storm after another is pummeling the west coast.
So today I want to continue and conclude the discussion about nuclear
experimentation and have you think a bit more with me about guidelines for
experimentation and how those might be embedded into law.
And I also want to start out by having you consider the central challenges that
were faced by the president,
uh,
the Defense Department and the Atomic Energy Commission.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it,
imagine yourself in the position of trying to figure out how rapidly to develop
the nuclear testing program and how you might guide it and what the central
purposes were.
So underlying,
uh,
the plan and the,
and the research was really the need to understand what our resilience would be
in the face of an attack.
The construction of weaponry that,
uh,
would be deliverable was one problem with that.
That was it more of a technical problem compared to wondering about how we might
survive an attack.
A central question associated with that is how to minimize human exposure for
what periods of time were necessary,
uh,
to prevent long term illness and how to decontaminate and restore the
environment.
Also,
how to convince the public of the need for continued testing as evidence,
uh,
kept leaking out,
into the,
uh,
into the press,
in a variety of ways,
uh,
but not,
not,
uh,
in small part because of the availability of detection equipment.
So Geiger counters were not,
uh,
they were not,
a technology that was required to be licensed or under the control of the
government.
Uh,
also the x ray film,
as I described,
being over exposed when it arrived at hospitals,
led people to understand that something was going on.
Uh,
they also face the challenge of how to maintain their secrets.
And they established a,
a,
a very large element within their bureaucracy,
uh,
to work on,
on different processes to,
to,
uh,
encourage workers to change their behavior in a way that would minimize the
opportunity for,
for leaking of secrets.
And then the central question that we'll look at today is if you have a
population that's been seriously exposed,
uh,
how do you manage,
how do you manage their complaints?
Uh,
what kind of provisions would you make for them in terms of longterm care or
compensation?
So,
in example,
after example among the 2000 tests that were conducted during this period,
uh,
you find workers and military officials being intensely exposed,
those closest to the site experience,
the highest degrees of radiation,
often without recognition of what they'd experienced or without,
uh,
understanding.
Uh,
and something that was really quite remarkable following the test and the Bikini
atoll when you had a hundred ships that were lined up in circling the blast
site,
uh,
was that almost instantaneously they created a massive amount of hazardous waste
and they had no understanding of what the implications might be for dealing with
that waste.
And a,
if you step back and you think about the location of the testing site in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean,
they were very conscious of what really is become a fundamental principle of
managing the environment and a producing environmental quality,
which is the idea that dilution is the solution to pollution.
So that a,
the expectation that,
uh,
the,
the technological danger will somehow dissipate,
uh,
and a,
as it moves further and further away from the point of release across space and
time to pose no danger and eventually go away.
And one interesting idea behind this idea behind that the presumption that
pollution is just going to go away is that it's pretty easy to conclude that if
you don't have sensitive detection tech technology.
So if you don't,
uh,
if you can't see a pollutant,
you can't,
uh,
taste it.
You can't smell it,
you can't feel it.
If you don't have a technologically sophisticated surveillance system in place,
people presume that it's gone away.
Uh,
so gradually they realize that they needed to understand this,
this distributional pattern more carefully.
Uh,
but the assumption was that the atmosphere and the oceans provided almost an
infinite sync,
uh,
an opportunity for diluting pollution.
Interesting idea.
So they looked at,
uh,
billions of pounds of hazardous waste in the form of the ships and wondered,
well,
what are we going to do with them?
It was kind of curious what they did initially.
They decided they were just going to spray them with water.
So they brought a boats alongside the ships and they started hosing them off,
uh,
assuming that a,
the radionuclides would somehow a wash off into the seat.
Uh,
the sailors on the ship started scrubbing them with soap.
then they found that the new Clyde's didn't dissipate.
Uh,
they use solvents.
they started bombing them with a ground up coconut shells.
Uh,
and nothing seemed to work.
It's kind of interesting here thinking to that,
that,
uh,
the sailors are standing on the deck of an irradiated destroyer,
with no protection gear.
Absolutely none.
Actually in 1987,
uh,
and the Chernobyl nuclear power plant explosion,
you see a similar degree of disregard for worker safety among those that were
brought in to put the fire out.
Uh,
and also to,
to,
uh,
clean up the mess,
dramatic misunderstanding on the part of those exposed,
uh,
despite the fact that,
the technical knowledge,
understanding the danger was pretty well understood among the people that were
giving the orders to,
uh,
the,
the Gis here.
So one of the solutions was,
well,
let's bury,
some of it will just sync some of the boats that are in the worst shape,
or we'll find out what parts of the ship or most irradiated,
and figure out what to do with those pieces.
Kind of an interesting thought.
So you've got this atoll,
which is basically the crater of an old volcano poking out of the Pacific Ocean
with a few strands of beach.
Uh,
ringing it a,
you put a hundred ships in there,
you,
you explode a bomb underwater.
Uh,
and Michael Oppenheimer,
who was the first director of the Los Alamos Laboratory,
uh,
responsible for the design of the first atomic bomb,
that was tested at Los Alamos in New Mexico.
Uh,
Michael Oppenheimer warned,
uh,
very vigorously against exploding a nuclear device underwater,
especially within an a tool because it would create,
in his words,
a toxic soup that would persist and contaminate the coral.
It would contaminate the underlying sands and it would contaminate the water and
marine marine life,
uh,
for decades,
but basically make that fisheries,
uh,
no longer suitable for human consumption.
Quite interesting to see the,
uh,
the moral and ethical arguments among the physicists who were responsible for
the design of these weapons back at that point in time.
Very compelling arguments not to use,
uh,
not to use these weapons,
that,
uh,
we're above a specific size.
Oppenheimer and his close colleagues and friends were branded as communists,
uh,
and,
and communist sympathizers.
There was some legitimacy for that.
He,
he was a socialist in his own political thinking,
uh,
but it was quite,
quite curious to see the way the Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
attacked him and,
set up spies to follow him and see who he was associating with.
You can now find this out by going back into this declassified documents
database.
Uh,
and then the trials that eventually were held,
uh,
to,
remove him from the Atomic Energy Commission.
So they've got this waste,
uh,
they,
they don't really know what to do with it.
Uh,
they began to take some of the ships and drag them back across the Pacific to us
ports.
So here is an example of an aircraft carrier that was dragged into the port at
San Francisco called Hunter's point.
Anybody here from San Francisco?
Well,
uh,
you may know this area next to the Bayview community.
It's quite an interesting area.
Well,
they didn't really know what to do there and this was a,
an experiment in progress and experiment largely without controls.
But imagine bringing the radioactive waste into one of the largest cities on the
west coast,
uh,
that was,
surrounded by people.
And then,
uh,
trying to remove the radioactive material from the ship,
by sandblasting it.
And sandblasting is a,
a notorious technology for simply a grinding of the way at,
uh,
at hard surfaces to remove the residues and what happens to it?
Well,
basically it just goes up into the air or if it's foggy or if it's raining,
it will rain down and then wash into eventually the,
the,
the bay hunter's point sits on the bed.
So you can see Hunter's point in this,
uh,
in this map from Google Earth,
over here.
And you see the Bayview district right now,
uh,
only,
probably less than a mile from a highway 101,
and like many other ports in the United States,
uh,
the port at Long Beach,
port a at Newport News,
Virginia,
up and down the east coast and the west coast and the Gulf coast.
You really find a,
a,
a contaminated soup of a variety of,
of different toxic substances,
often in rather close proximity to very densely populated areas.
So in this case,
it's also quite curious that,
uh,
this is now the site of a very active protest.
Uh,
many people that live adjacent to these military sites are quite concerned about
their exposures.
Uh,
and it also is the,
the subject,
uh,
the target of renewal effort in San Francisco.
The San Francisco Redevelopment Authority,
uh,
hopes to take a 1400 acre track of land and redevelop.
It is also happens to be a center,
uh,
of,
ethnic minorities in San Francisco,
especially African Americans.
And,
uh,
these people are quite concerned that the same redevelopment effects,
will occur at Bayview as occurred in the Fillmore district.
Uh,
when the government came in,
took over property,
basically forced out tenants and the poorest and the community,
uh,
and gentrified it,
dramatically changing the socio and demographic characteristics of the area.
So gradually by,
uh,
the,
the late 1990s,
we had a pretty good image of what happened to all of these,
uh,
radionuclides at least in the lower 48.
So the surveillance was best in the 48 states,
uh,
also in Alaska because Alaska was the site of a variety of underground tests by
the u s but it also was a recipient of much of the fallout that came across from
Siberia where a number of the Soviet tests were conducted.
So that,
uh,
the,
the understanding of the distribution of risk,
uh,
was really quite sophisticated.
I'd say probably more so than any other chemical that has been studied or
regulated in us history,
so that these data were aggregated by the National Cancer Institute,
uh,
county by county.
And you can see the,
uh,
the red pattern indicating areas that,
residents received the highest exposure,
uh,
measured in millisieverts.
And,
uh,
you also see kind of unusual patterns developing in the,
northern rocky region,
but also as far away as a,
uh,
Indiana,
Illinois.
And then,
uh,
as I showed you the other day,
as the,
uh,
the cloud had squirreled down from Canada and met her rainstorm in New England,
the Vermont New York border as well.
So this became the,
uh,
the foundation for a rather interesting compensation scheme on the part of the
government.
So if you lived in specific states,
uh,
or in specific counties,
you are presumed to have a certain dose of radiation that made you eligible for
compensation at specified levels,
depending upon the illness that you could demonstrate.
So you needed a physician's diagnosis of a particular illness.
It might be a thyroid disease,
it could be a thyroid cancer,
it could be a leukemia,
it could be bone cancer.
Uh,
it could be,
uh,
different types of blood disorders.
It could be genetic mutations.
But if you could demonstrate that you had an illness that was plausibly related
to exposure to an array of radionuclides,
uh,
it was matched up against this map.
Uh,
so that,
that became the formula for a level of compensation.
The people that lived,
uh,
downwind are called the downwinders and $50,000 became eligible,
became available to those that met the criteria that were physically present,
could demonstrate that they had a residency,
uh,
in these areas for specific periods of time.
The radiation exposure compensation act of 1990,
uh,
provided for compassionate,
payments to individuals who contracted these cancers and other diseases as a
result of exposure,
uh,
during the testing period.
And also for those that were mining uranium,
the became the,
the,
uh,
the predominant fuel,
that was enriched,
uh,
to,
produce the,
uh,
nuclear fuels,
those,
that a mine,
the uranium,
but also those that,
that,
uh,
transport it so that the,
the miners and the transporters,
uh,
we're well recognized as another occupational group,
that experienced high levels of exposure as well as elevated incidents of,
of disease when compared to a occupation or excuse me,
uh,
individuals that,
that,
uh,
had received lower doses of radiation.
So a payment of 75,000 was available to people that were onsite participants.
In other words,
they were actually stationed there.
The,
the military officials that you saw with the goggles and the sitting in the lawn
chairs with the shorts on a,
or those on the decks of the cruisers are those that actually were involved in
and moving into,
uh,
the region and,
working on the boats and trying to figure out what to do with a mass.
So the,
those that had participated in restoration efforts also are eligible.
Here's an example of a uranium mine worker spending a good amount of time
underground,
uh,
and being dosed at a fairly significant level on a routine basis.
So $100,000 was available to those that,
that,
uh,
had had been employed either above ground or below ground.
Uh,
if the mines were located in certain states,
uh,
and if they had worked at any time during the period beginning in 1942 and then
ending in 1971.
So this is kind of interesting to me because it,
it really is an example of the government saying,
well,
here's a trade off.
You know,
we really need to conduct this test.
Uh,
we know that these damages are likely to accrue a,
let's develop a scientific foundation for understanding the probability of the
link between a causal link between the exposure and the adverse health effect.
And A,
we've got to figure out a way of compensating these people,
uh,
that this,
this is an approach.
Congress thought would,
uh,
subvert a class action lawsuits.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they were largely right.
My nephew is an example of works for the Justice Department and he works on a
native American claims.
Uh,
uh,
for those native American communities that,
were believed to be intensely exposed.
So he,
he goes to the community,
uh,
he interviews people,
using,
uh,
a fairly extensive survey form.
Uh,
he tries to figure out,
uh,
their medical condition and this is especially problematic.
You can imagine for impoverished groups because they do not have adequate
medical care so that they,
they all also,
uh,
given the absence of,
of a,
you know,
routine care,
it's very common for the poorest in society to develop illnesses,
uh,
that,
progress until they're quite serious before they are diagnosed.
So the wealthier in most societies have access to medical care,
uh,
that,
allows for early diagnosis,
early treatment,
uh,
so that,
the,
the ultimate damage is often less among the wealthy.
It was a political science professor,
uh,
who,
was trained at Yale and,
uh,
argued a in an article that a being richer is being safer in the world quite
generally,
so that a,
the richer have higher educations,
they have a higher capacity to understand risk.
They have also a higher capacity to take action to manage risk and the,
in the event of damage,
uh,
they either are able to,
receive compensation from insurance policies that they paid for or they have the
opportunity to go out and seek a high quality medical care.
It's an interesting kind of an argument.
So Richard is safer,
uh,
written by Aaron will [inaudible] who was a rather famous,
a political science professor at the University of California.
So what's happened in terms of these compensation efforts?
The downwinders,
those that simply lived in the area,
uh,
have now received about $600,000,
excuse me,
$600 million.
About 12,000 different claims had been approved.
The onsite participants have been awarded about $91 million.
Uh,
the uranium miners and,
uh,
the millers have received about a $600 million in the or transporters about $24
million.
So a total of about 20,000 people have been compensated at a level of one point
$3 billion.
Now back up and think,
well,
how many people actually were exposed to during this period of time?
Well,
the cancer institute did an estimate,
which was rather revealing,
uh,
by studying tissue samples from around the world.
Their estimate,
uh,
by the mid 1990s,
when the total world population was roughly 5.6,
5.7 billion people,
their estimate of those exposed was 5 billion people in the world exposed.
So any sort of compensatory scheme such as this,
uh,
would have to set boundaries,
would have to set limits.
Uh,
and our limits were set at our national border despite the fact that we
contaminated,
uh,
tracks of land,
in different parts of the world.
And it was not as easily,
uh,
easily predicted.
As you might imagine,
given the,
the,
the role that climate played a relative to the intersection of the rainstorms,
uh,
with the dust clouds and also the long residency time of the other radionuclides
in the atmosphere.
So that Mexico,
Canada,
parts of Europe,
we're very heavily exposed.
Uh,
but they did not have any compensation scheme in place.
Now I'd like to switch gears for a moment and talk briefly about medical
experimentation.
And you may recall from earlier history courses that,
that,
uh,
the Nuremberg trial in 1946 produced eventually consensus about ethical for
human error experimentation.
Uh,
well,
the Nazis were,
were,
uh,
quite active at experimenting on humans and violating,
most principals that now have been adopted by a nations or among nations and
also principals that have adopted by medical associations around the world.
So the,
the,
the Nuremberg trial was,
uh,
was,
conducted in reaction to a horrific experimentation,
uh,
without seeking consent,
without providing knowledge about what the purpose was.
Uh,
what the,
uh,
risks might be a without anesthesia.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
there was no sense of what the humanitarian benefit might be.
Uh,
and also kind of raising a rather interesting question.
when you think about medical experimentation,
how should you conceive of the locus of the balancing that would go on?
No fundamental principle of medicine is at first,
uh,
the first principle is do no harm.
Well,
experimentation may do harm.
If you conduct a clinical trial using a new drug or you wonder about a new
technology such as a nuclear weapon or exposure to waste from a nuclear reactor
a then you need to think about,
uh,
you know,
what the net benefit to the person might be.
Is it okay to think about this question,
uh,
as one where the individual that is exposed,
deliberately in the experiment,
uh,
whether or not the net benefit should be balanced against the individual damage.
In other words,
is it ethically responsible to think that a collective benefit in terms of,
of making the world safer?
If you believe that by,
uh,
experimenting with nuclear weapons and trying to figure out what our resigns,
he would be a,
does it make sense to balance that against harm that would,
would,
uh,
be accrued by the individual?
So that now when we,
when we think about,
uh,
the,
design and license of a new drug,
uh,
we construct the calculus of,
of good versus harm,
uh,
at the level of the individual as opposed to at the level of society.
So for years I debated with chemical,
uh,
industry,
officials about,
uh,
the,
ethical nature of planning.
But it's okay for us to be exposed to pesticides,
uh,
in food and drinking water or the farm workers breathing the fumes in the air as
a plane flies over.
It's a case and we'll talk about more next,
uh,
over the next couple of weeks.
Is it okay to,
to justify that based on the claim that,
well,
you know,
if you use pesticides a,
then we're going to produce a lot more food in the world.
Uh,
so that will avoid starvation.
We'll avoid diseases.
So that's an example where you conduct the calculus at a,
at a very gross scale saying,
yes,
the population is exposed to these chemicals at a relatively low levels in
drinking water and food occupationally at a higher level.
Uh,
but it's really worth it because we want to balance that over the net collective
benefit of having an nutritious and sufficient food supply so that these are the
basic questions,
uh,
that were,
addressed in the Nuremberg trial,
but also surround the question about how to manage a compensation efforts.
So 23 medical doctors were on trial for murder,
torture,
and other atrocities,
uh,
performed in the broad name,
in their testimony of medical science in concentration camps.
Now,
in response to this,
the American Medical Association eventually adopted guidelines.
It included these voluntary and understanding consent of the subject,
prior animal experimentation,
appropriate medical supervision,
those treated we're expected to accrue some benefit or there should be some
overwhelming,
huge humanitarian purpose that served if the benefit would not be accrued by the
individual.
So thinking about these guidelines and then thinking about the atomic energy
commissions,
uh,
approach themselves to,
experimenting with humans is an interesting topic.
And if you go back and take a look at the Department of Energy Files,
uh,
which you can do on their website.
If you,
if you simply take a look at,
uh,
the release of documents that occurred during the 1990s,
many of which had been classified,
just see a whole array of experiments.
Uh,
here's an example of isotope injections at Brookhaven national lab.
where the individual being injected had no knowledge of what he was being
injected with no understanding of the,
uh,
the radioactive tracers that were being used to understand how these compounds
get distributed in the body.
So,
I mean,
one of the,
one of the concerns at that point in time was we're releasing this technology.
We're creating all these new,
uh,
radionuclides.
How do they behave inside the human body?
Well,
we all know that a radioactive tracers now are,
are,
are used to track the movement of,
of different to pharmaceuticals to the body to make sure that they can reach the
target or Oregon,
uh,
and,
and actually,
uh,
cure an illness or,
or,
uh,
particular problems such as a bacterial infection.
So that,
uh,
being able to understand,
the movement of chemicals through the body,
where they reside,
what their persistence is,
what their metabolic rate is,
how they break down into other products and whether or not those,
uh,
are likely to be greeted,
excluded by urine and feces or excluded by a water vapor from your breath.
So these are all questions that are circulating in their minds and provided in
their thinking,
a rationale for experimenting on humans without asking for their permission,
without telling them the logic behind it and with no presumption that the
individual would benefit from that exposure.
So 81 studies were conducted that involve children's participation or
participation by pregnant women in radiation research.
21 of these were supported by federal funds determined to be non therapeutic.
In other words,
no benefit would accrue to the individual that participated.
Now also think about this and think about,
think about the logic of employing children and uh,
whether or not it is reasonable to assume that a child would have the capacity
to understand the nature of the risk,
to understand the perceived humanitarian benefit of participating in the
research,
uh,
and also to,
be capable of self monitoring for physiological effects that might be associated
with the exposures.
So by the way,
we,
uh,
we fall down in this expectation that children's somehow,
should be capable of,
of understanding risks by education or via product labeling,
whereas there are 80 million children in the United States today that really
have quite limited capacity to understand the nature of the kinds of
environmental threats or environmental health threats that we've been discussing
so far in the course.
Now that to me is,
is quite interesting.
[inaudible] if you choose to,
uh,
to educate or to label as a management strategy to contain risk or to manage a
technological hazard or pollution that,
uh,
another good example of that would be,
the way we manage mercury in fish,
we don't set a limit for mercury in fish and then take mercury,
partake the fish that are contaminated beyond the limit out of the marketplace.
Instead,
what do we do?
We post signs on the side of a riverbank or on the side of a lake and assume
that that sign is going to be sufficient as a,
as a warning device,
do not consume more than x amount of fish taken from this river.
The logic being too to contain their mercury exposure.
So the,
the idea that,
uh,
you've got a large proportion of the public that is either illiterate,
that,
uh,
is not a technically competent and in order to understand that the technical
nature of the warning or not capable of managing their own health,
uh,
in,
in response to an adverse event.
So here are a couple of,
uh,
examples of the way that the atomic energy commission was thinking about this.
Uh,
here,
the AEC medical advisor is recommending the suppression of evidence of plutonium
injection injections.
So not informing people that are part of experiments.
There are a large number of papers he argued that do not violate national
security but do cause considerable concern papers referring to levels of soil
and water contamination surrounding ADC installations.
Idle speculation on the future.
Genetic effects of radiation and papers dealing with potential process hazards
to employees are definitely prejudicial to the best interest to the government.
Every such release is reflected in an increase in insurance claims,
increased difficulty in labor relations and adverse public sentiment.
Very,
very curious.
So,
you know,
they're arguing that uh,
uh,
a logic for secrecy,
a logic for not seeking informed consent is that it's gonna make their life
tougher.
You could use the same argument to,
uh,
basically scuttle a surveillance system.
So basically argue,
well that's not monitor where this stuff goes because if we do,
then somebody is going to find out about it and it can be used against us.
It could foster public opinion that would,
would,
uh,
because Congress to,
to,
uh,
react to their constituency and argue,
gee,
you know,
we shouldn't continue with this testing program.
So they're very deeply into this line of logic trying to figure out how they can
maintain public support.
Uh,
but how the very act of conducting a surveillance or environmental monitoring
could undermine their longterm plans.
In another example,
at Vanderbilt hospital between 1945 and 1947,
829 pregnant women were fed a radioactive tracer cocktails,
another at the University of Tennessee at the College of Medicine and the John
Gaston Hospital,
uh,
two African American Women Ages 22 and 33 or administered iodine one 31.
While they were nursing infants,
four months of age and both mothers had been diagnosed with thyroid cancer.
This is curious.
I mean,
you take mothers that had thyroid cancer and you would dose them with iodine,
which lodges in the thyroid,
thyroid,
uh,
that had been irradiated
infants continued to nurse and the levels of iodine,
one 31 were monitored in the mother's breast milk and thyroid and the infant's
firearm on the infant's accumulation of item one 31 in their thyroids with
significant prompting the researchers to warn against administration of Ida and
one 31 to lactating women.
So the thinking here that,
uh,
they understood clearly that,
that the,
the new Clyde mood from mom to,
uh,
the young to the kids,
via breastmilk,
uh,
but,
they,
they really had no,
uh,
they had no concerns about what the long term health effects might be on the
women at Harvard Boston University in Massachusetts General Hospital.
Uh,
there was an experiment conducted on what they then called mentally retarded
children,
uh,
in 1961 at the Wrentham state school.
And it was designed to understand whether written on radioactive iodine could
block thyroid uptake of radioactive,
uh,
iodine,
or I had on one 31,
the National Institute of Health or the Atomic Energy Commission and the Quaker
Oats Company,
uh,
also conducted a similar study at the Walter Fernald School in Massachusetts,
also described by the AEC as being a school for the mentally retarded.
And the children were fed breakfast food containing radioactive iron and calcium
Quaker oats company.
Now that's interesting.
A Quaker oats was extremely concerned about contaminants moving into their
processed foods.
Uh,
and they were also worried about,
uh,
whether or not they might be able to block the uptake of some radionuclides by
four to find some of their foods,
whether the other nutrients.
So could you put God calcium,
uh,
in oatmeal and a,
would that have an effect?
Well,
uh,
you know,
perhaps,
uh,
that,
that's an interesting study.
Uh,
perhaps you would want to carry that study out,
uh,
on animals before you conducted on,
on children.
And,
and why would you choose,
uh,
the Wrentham school or the,
the Fernald school as,
as a locus of,
um,
uh,
this type of,
of study.
So nine boys between 10 and 15 years in age and one a 21 year old served as
subjects.
Uh,
and they were divided into two groups.
So one receiving intravenous injections of calcium,
45,
and the others received it orally and the breakfast cereals.
And they were trying to figure out where this went in the human body.
Uh,
and what role it played in,
in,
uh,
blocking a uptake of,
other nuclides.
And several letters were sent to the parents of the students,
uh,
who would become members of the science club if they agreed to participate.
So the first appeal was made to,
to,
uh,
the students.
Would you like to participate?
And,
uh,
it's kind of interesting to think about,
the letter that was sent to the parents.
So I'm going to read this to you.
It gives you some insight into their,
their thinking and their,
their methods.
Do your parent in previous years.
We have done some examination and connection with the Nutritional Department of
the Massachusetts Institute of Technology with the purposes of helping to
improve the nutrition of our children and to help them in general and for
checking up on the children.
Uh,
we occasionally need to take some blood samples which are then analyze the blood
samples are taken after one test meal,
which consists of a special breakfast meal containing a certain amount of
calcium,
no mention of the radio knew Clyde.
We have asked for volunteers to give,
uh,
a a sample of blood once a month for three months and your son has agreed to
volunteer,
uh,
because the boys who belonged to the science club have many additional
privileges.
They get a quarter milk daily during that time.
They're taken to a baseball game,
a to the beach and to some outside dinners and they enjoy it greatly.
I hope that you have no objection that your son is voluntarily participating in
this study.
The first study,
we'll start on Monday,
June 8th.
And if you've not expressed any objections,
we will assume that your son may participate.
Interesting.
So,
uh,
first the presumption that that,
they would,
uh,
legitimately ask the child before the parent,
the presumption that if they heard nothing back from the parent who might be
traveling or whatever,
uh,
that,
they would go ahead with the experiment.
Uh,
so
this,
uh,
these studies studies,
once they were released and came to the attention of the Department of Energy,
uh,
and,
President Clinton,
uh,
in 1995,
led the administration to issue an executive order on declassification.
So during the 1990s,
uh,
the Clinton administration was responsible for declassifying,
almost 400 million pages of material,
20% or so,
a reduction in the total backlog.
Uh,
but the new new cla declassification programs,
uh,
I have been,
excuse me,
new classification programs had been initiated by the CIA,
the national security agency,
and the national reconnaissance office.
So that this period between 1990 and 2000 was a period where we were
declassifying more than we were classifying.
And a following,
a 2001 September 11th attack on the World Trade Center.
Uh,
we've clearly gone in the opposite direction.
The Department of Energy,
uh,
was extremely embarrassed by the release of these studies.
And,
and,
uh,
the former secretary,
Hazel O'Leary,
undertook what she called an openness initiative in 1993.
Uh,
and I went back through all of her records of the Atomic Energy Commission,
uh,
and once that was transformed into the Department of Energy,
the Nuclear Regulatory Commission and,
and,
uh,
declassified a large amount of information,
the National Security Administration is now the largest intelligence agency in
the world.
And,
uh,
it is important to know that they have a power to classify at all levels,
and they also are exempt from the federal freedom of Information Act,
which means that you can not request any information from them,
or they have a,
they have the ability to make the judgment to decline any request,
uh,
and not give you any reason for that.
So last year we spent,
uh,
this is actually a year and a half old now.
Uh,
we spent almost $25 billion,
uh,
on secret programs,
secret programs for surveillance,
for containment technologies to,
uh,
eavesdrop via computer reading emails.
Uh,
also watching the way that people surf the Internet.
so that the surveillance efforts on the part of the government that remain
classified,
I'll have never been higher in human history.
So,
uh,
let's,
pause and reflect over the past couple of lectures and think about some of the
key lessons,
one lesson that,
uh,
is extremely important and I hope five years down the road,
if you have,
if I have any hope of you remember anything about this course,
I want you to think about one issue.
And that is if you want to manage the environment,
you've got to think a lot about the principle of persistence.
How long does a danger persist,
how is it distributed?
Uh,
how does it move through the environment,
the atmosphere of the water,
the soils,
and the food?
And I'm struck,
uh,
I'm,
I'm really struck by the,
uh,
importance of food as being a primary route of exposure to many of the
radionuclides in this case.
Uh,
but it's also the primary routes of exposure to many pollutants and a other
synthetic chemicals in the food supply.
Today,
I gave a lecture yesterday afternoon on,
on,
uh,
regulation of food in the United States.
And I came to the conclusion that,
uh,
food is often the predominant route of exposure and you often need to think
about controlling air pollution because of how it might get into the food
supply.
So really,
uh,
the strontium 90 story,
the had I won 31 story and,
uh,
also the CCM story as well is one about air pollution.
It's about,
uh,
having,
the idea that it's okay to release this material to the environment and that
it's not going to come back to haunt us in the form of water pollution or air
pollution.
But where it seems to pose the greatest amount of threat where it concentrates
the most is in the food chain.
So if,
uh,
if it gets into the atmosphere,
it's likely to get into every other compartment of the environment and then it's
likely to boomerang back to us,
uh,
in the form of a food contaminant.
This case demonstrated also,
uh,
the length of time,
the enormous amount of science that needed to be conducted in order to figure
out what happens to these chemicals in the human body.
Yes,
you could think from a medical researchers perspective that it was legitimate to
two.
I think about the need for human experimentation to figure out where these
compounds go in the human body.
Uh,
and,
and also to think about the need for long term medical surveillance to figure
out what the effects of exposure at different doses might be.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there are experimental guidelines that a,
you could now imagine that you would want in place before the government would
have authority to conduct those,
those types of tests.
Uh,
this is a case,
uh,
probably the best case in the history that we've got.
Uh,
the history of environmental science,
about expert understanding of a dose response relationship,
uh,
understanding what dose posed a specific threat.
And also it is pro perhaps the first case,
uh,
in the United States at least,
where we had an understanding that these chemicals behave very differently,
uh,
in the fetus.
Uh,
they behave very differently in people that,
uh,
have a different genetic characteristics.
Uh,
they'd behave differently in the young compared to the old,
uh,
and that they concentrate in different parts of the body,
at different ages.
So this idea of susceptibility that now has become a hallmark of a US
environmental law and really a fundamental principle of European environmental
law.
Looking and thinking about,
uh,
everybody is not being average,
but looking at differences in physiology and these other characteristics,
susceptibility is,
is now an extremely important,
uh,
factor in,
in thinking about risk and therefore becomes a critical foundation for thinking
about different risk management strategies like setting levels for allowable
contamination in air,
food and water.
Don't forget in this case as well,
that uh,
uh,
this entire history took place between 46,
1945 actually the first test and 1963 when the atmospheric testing stopped by
the limited test ban treaty.
So in this compressed 18 year period,
what environmental law is,
did we have in place,
uh,
to control exposure.
We had nothing.
We had no clean air act.
We had no safe drinking water act.
We had no toxic substance control act.
We had no superfund act too to try to figure out what to do with these highly
contaminated sites.
We had no food,
drug and cosmetic act that looked at radionuclides levels in different foods.
Uh,
we had no food and Drug Administration that,
uh,
might be responsible for looking for radionuclides in different types of foods.
Uh,
we had no understanding of whether or not the,
the chemicals bio concentrated during the process of,
of,
uh,
taking a,
a,
a raw corn and turning it into corn oil,
or extracting the water out of a grape to make a reason so that,
uh,
none of this regulatory authority existed during this 18 year period.
So,
uh,
at the same time,
what we'll see over the next several weeks is that,
uh,
this history is extremely important and providing a paradigm for understanding
environmental quality,
uh,
and the,
distribution of pollution that was picked up and was dropped into food safety
law,
dropped into air quality law,
dropped into thinking about hazardous materials management.
So it's become a very important component of environmental law,
also a leader in the term when we think about the current status and the future
of,
of nuclear power.
Uh,
we're not going to,
we're not going to move into this discussion too deeply today,
but I want you to think about the similarity between what we learned,
uh,
in,
by 1963 and then what we learned from the Chernobyl event.
Uh,
so Chernobyl,
uh,
is a nuclear reactor located in,
in,
uh,
just outside of Kiev and a little village called Pripyat.
Uh,
and it exploded and it caught on fire.
And the,
the,
uh,
the roof blew off of it back in 1986 and I don't know,
let's see.
1986,
I,
I suppose that you would not,
most of you would not have been alive in 1986,
uh,
but your parents would,
would remember this and you are walking around probably still with radionuclides
in your body that,
uh,
resulted from your intake of foods that were contaminated as the amount of,
of a material that reach the atmosphere.
Also went into global circulation,
also rained down around the world,
uh,
and,
exposed to almost everyone,
uh,
at a lower level than it was experienced during the atomic weapons testing.
A couple of key points of comparison here.
One is that the expectation on the part of the Soviet government,
uh,
then responsible for managing this site was that they needed to manage and test
for contamination in close proximity to that site.
They were most worried about getting people out of that zone by evacuating them
out,
uh,
within roughly about a 10 to 15 kilometer radius.
If you remember that donut,
remember the donut that I had up there surrounding the map,
uh,
in Nevada that demonstrated the way that the atomic energy commission had
similarly underestimated,
uh,
the movement of radionuclides.
Uh,
the same happened here gradually after they expanded their testing,
they found that the eventual distributional pattern is designated by the red on
this map is the most intensely contaminated zone.
So a few,
uh,
look,
look at this.
You see that a certain of these zones were confiscated,
some were confiscated,
uh,
even more than 150 miles away from the site of,
of,
of the fire.
Uh,
there is a very important story here about the absence of surveillance,
uh,
leading to a perception of,
of,
uh,
environmental purity.
So that gradually over a period of time,
you know,
as a Soviet Union collapsed in the amount of surveillance expanded,
the quality of the testing got better.
They realize that these new Clyde's had a seriously contaminated,
a huge track of,
of landscape in the eastern European nations.
And they,
they basically made to agricultural productivity impossible.
Uh,
they made future forestry in this area.
Impossible.
The forests surrounding a Kia of now have taken up the radionuclides.
Uh,
so if you,
uh,
if you cut those down and you build a house out of the material,
you basically would be exposing your,
you yourself or your family to the material or if there is a serious forest fire
in that region today,
and there's been about a six or seven year drought and Eastern Europe.
So this is a serious concern at forest fire would basically cause the,
these radionuclides to go back up into circulation.
Okay.
Just as on Bikini atoll where they decided,
well,
you know,
let's restore the site,
let's take off the top meter or two of soil and we'll bring in fresh soil that
so that they can,
they can grow crops again.
They still thought that,
uh,
this would be the effective,
restoration technique,
uh,
in the,
Ukraine.
But they found that,
uh,
it was an overwhelming area that had been contaminated.
3,200 square kilometers,
uh,
76,000 square kilometers,
had a detectable levels of,
of,
uh,
radiation and 3 million people lived in these zones.
So what do you do with it?
What do you,
what do you do with,
uh,
the,
the structures that have been contaminated?
What do you do with the equipment that's been contaminated?
Uh,
in this case,
they decided they were going to bury it.
Uh,
so they dug deep trenches and they'd buried,
uh,
the military equipment they built and they dug,
dug trenches.
The,
the drove the fire trucks into them and buried the firetrucks.
They buried cars.
Uh,
so that they basically figured,
well,
this is one solution to the problem.
In a slight aside,
it was kind of interesting that,
uh,
when they would vary the cars,
people would be watching as they buried the cars and then they would go and dig
up the cars and take the car parts out at night,
uh,
and then sell the car parts on the black market.
There's really quite a similarity here between,
uh,
the problem of,
of creating a hazardous waste such as this that's been contaminated by a nuclear
debris in Chernobyl.
And the,
the idea of creating a radiated hulks of ships,
uh,
and wondering what to do about it so that,
you know,
once again we'll see a kind of a pattern of denial followed by a pattern of
gradually increased sophistication and surveillance leading to a recognition
that,
oh my gosh,
this problem is much bigger than we thought it was.
Okay.
So a few concluding thoughts about this section.
Uh,
one is that a secrecy is a very important form of social control or regulation.
So if we give the government the right to maintain secrets,
we're giving them the right to control our knowledge to control our
intelligence.
Uh,
in this case demonstrates that a secrecy concentrated knowledge among those with
authority and power.
Uh,
it basically inhibits broad public literacy and intelligence.
It undermines democracy because if you don't understand these issues,
you certainly are not going to be an effective participant in decision making
about how to manage risks.
And these are often pretty technical decisions.
Uh,
it prevents accountability.
So the bureaucrats inside the Atomic Energy Commission and the defense like this
part about it very much.
It basically means that they're not accountable to anybody except to those that
also have security clearances.
It may restrict individual liberty as it has a restricting rights of a nine 11
detainees.
It can enhance the persuasive power of elites.
It provides them with narrative advantage to give their interpretation of the
story.
So if you don't have the evidence to,
uh,
to,
to task,
to or to contest a,
their conclusions,
uh,
you have no political power.
And also it turns secrets,
uh,
into extremely valuable commodities.
Uh,
so in a sense,
a secrecy creates intellectual property.
Uh,
the more valuable that property is,
uh,
the shorter it's half life is.
I'll leave you with one thought,
uh,
from Albert Einstein.
It's not enough for a handful of experts to attempt the solution of a problem to
solve it and then to apply it.
The restriction of knowledge to an elite group destroys the spirit of society
and leads to its intellectual impoverishment.
Okay.
Thank you.
Have a good weekend.